sound editing is very much like sex it's
usually done alone late at night
surrounded by electronic gadgets and
let's face it if you really want to do
it right it's always best when you pay
top dollar for a true professional way
what are you sayin sound edit Oscar
sound editing I just didn't want to make
it sound like we were making fun of the
craft of sound editing they don't take
these things lightly no no I I think
these guys always had a pretty good
sense
nature point here are the nominees for
best sound editing Sean McCormack in
Comi Asghar for Apocalypto lawn bender
for Blood Diamond
Alan Robert Murray and Bob asmin for
Flags of Our Fathers Alan Robert Murray
and Bob Osmond for letters from iwo jima
Christopher boys and George waters the
second for Pirates of the Caribbean Dead
Man's Chest and the Oscar goes to Bob
Osmond for letters from iwo jima Robert
Allen Marie's father
marine survivor of Iwo Jima
you
oh okay
well first of all I'd like to thank the
Academy our distinguished director Clint
Eastwood producer Steven Spielberg Paul
Haggis
and Rob Lorentz the incredible support
from everyone in the Malpass of family
Warner Brothers and DreamWorks support
from the United States Marine Corps to
our wives and children for their
continued support and understanding our
exceptional picture and sound editors on
letters in the mixed team of Greg rude
laughs John writes and Dave Campbell and
finally thank you to my father and all
the brave honorable men and women in
uniform who in a time of crisis have all
made that decision to defend their
personal freedom and liberty no matter
what the sacrifice thank you